y en las noticias de salud nos acompaña
como siempre nuestra periodista más
Romero sala Mar buenos días para ustedes
bienvenida Buenos días María Clara bueno
Comencemos hablando de la viruela del
mono porque se conoció que puede ser
letal en los casos en los que también se
padezca VIH no es así sí son
conclusiones bastante graves de un nuevo
estudio publicado en este sentido sobre
todo para personas que tienen VIH y que
están inmunosuprimidas es decir que
tienen problemas con su sistema inmune
el estudio se hizo con 380 pacientes que
tenían infecciones como decimos
avanzadas de VIH es decir que sus
células llamadas cd4 estaban por debajo
de los 350 estas células son unos
linfocitos son unas células del sistema
inmune y su conteo suele servir como
indicador de cómo de Avanzada o
descontrolada se llama a veces también
está la infección de VIH lo normal es
tener por ejemplo a partir de unas 500
en este estudio todos tenían menos de
350 básicamente lo que describen es
prácticamente como si fuera una nueva
enfermedad
tomaron en Box fulminante no por su
gravedad porque no responde a muchos
tratamientos porque es muy dolorosa no
son las lesiones de la piel que ya
conocemos de esta enfermedad pero mucho
más graves y porque llega a afectar
otros órganos en este estudio 27 de los
pacientes que se describen terminaron
perdiendo la vida vamos a revisar los
resultados principales en cifras vemos
que en los pacientes con menos conteo de
estas células cd4 es decir con un
sistema inmune más comprometido más de
un cuarto de ellos fallecieron y más
prácticamente tres cuartos Perdón
necesitaron hospitalización no la
situación mejora a medida que este
conteo es más alto hasta llegar a que la
mayoría de pacientes pues ni siquiera
necesitaron hospitalización recordamos
entonces que no significa no tener VIH y
tener en va a significar la muerte pero
para los casos con esta infección más
avanzada si puede ser muy grave bueno Y
usted ya nos adelantaba que esto es
considerado como una nueva enfermedad
cuéntenos entonces qué síntomas padecen
las personas que tienen y también VIH
pues primero son estas lesiones de la
piel que son mucho más graves y que
también las han descrito como necrosadas
es decir que el tejido que afecta
termina muriendo no se termina muriendo
este tejido Si vemos el listado también
que hace el estudio en rojo están las
personas con el sistema inmune más
comprometido de nuevo en verde las que
menos vemos también como hablan por
ejemplo de complicaciones respiratorias
puede llegar a afectar a los pulmones
también de complicaciones bacteriales es
decir que favorece que aparezcan
infecciones secundarias que compliquen
la enfermedad gastrointestinal es
también no algunos de los casos se
describieron con perforaciones
intestinales o incluso rectales Así que
pasamos de una enfermedad que era
dolorosa pero que con tratamiento y con
seguimiento se conseguía superar con
bastante facilidad fuera de los países
endémicos la mortalidad fue de 0,1%
aproximadamente a una enfermedad con
muchas más complejidades mucho más
difícil de tratar bueno y no solo en
estos pacientes hay fuertes
implicaciones sino que además hombre es
gay y bisexuales están padeciendo
también una particularidad Cuál es claro
sabemos que fuera de los países
endémicos esta enfermedad se ha
extendido sobre todo entre esta
población no entre hombres que tienen
sexo con hombres Aunque es muy
importante recordar que no solo es
exclusiva las infecciones de esta
población a todo el mundo puede
contagiarse tanto de VIH como de como de
empox pero también sucede que con el VIH
la población una de las poblaciones de
riesgos son precisamente hombres gay
hombres bisexuales y otras poblaciones
vulnerables Como por ejemplo
trabajadores y trabajadoras sexuales de
nuevo insistimos no todo el mundo que
tenga VIH significa que esté en un
riesgo letal de muerte sí contrae la
viruela del mono pero sí vemos que eso
sucede con las personas que por ejemplo
no tengan acceso antirretrovirales a
estas terapias que hacen que el VIH se
pueda vivir como una condición Crónica
pero que no terminan con un sistema
inmune comprometido precisamente las
personas que no tienen acceso a esta
terapia antirretroviral suelen ser
comunidades más empobrecidas con menos
acceso a la salud menos recursos también
con muchísimo más estigma Entonces si
estas dos condiciones de salud terminan
superponiéndose al final quien queda
digamos en esa encrucijada en esa
intersección son los mismos las personas
Eso de nuevo con menos recursos con más
estigma no Y entonces existe ese riesgo
de que se enquiste el empox como una
condición grave En esta población
nosotros recogimos datos de pues qué
población tiene acceso precisamente los
retrovirales que es lo que podría
proteger los de esta versión fulminante
del empox y vemos Que en América Latina
el 62% de la población que vive con VIH
tiene acceso antirretrovirales eso
significa que aproximadamente un tercio
no tiene acceso a estas terapias una
proporción parecida en la región
africana y en la región del Caribe es la
mitad es decir la mitad de población que
vive con VIH no tiene acceso a este tipo
de terapias bueno Y si no hay acceso
completo a estos antirretrovirales mar
cómo se pueden proteger frente a riesgo
Pues la primera recomendación del grupo
de científicos que hizo este estudio que
se publicó en The lanced Por cierto es
que cada caso de inbox que se detecte se
haga la prueba del VIH no y que si se
tiene VIH se haga prueba para saber sus
defensas y saber cómo responder segundo
que se priorice en la vacunación también
de empox a la población con VIH pero
tercero una de las recomendaciones que
hacían quizás de las más importantes es
que se incluya esta condición la viruela
del mono como una enfermedad definitoria
del sida que significan son esas
enfermedades básicamente que cuando
empeoran o cuando se detectan en un
paciente infectado de VIH se determina
que esa persona ya ha desarrollado sida
que es la enfermedad provocada por el
virus de la inmunodeficiencia humana
entonces bueno hablan de esta forma
grave necrosante no con síntomas graves
y hasta con la muerte que entonces
podrían pedirle pues como decíamos a la
OMS que se incluya esta enfermedad Como
una enfermedad definitoria del sida la
OMS ha dicho que lo estudiara mar
Gracias por explicarnos todo este
informe Muchas gracias a ti María Clara